je fais cette activité pour pouvoir
donner de l'espoir aux prisonniers
d'opinion il ya plein de personnes dans
le monde elle qui pense à vous et qui
vous trouvent courageux question de vous
soutenir et de nous faire sourire
on va écrire des lettres pour encourager
les personnes qui se sentent en prison
à nice est en national avec le marathon
propose changer le bruit en paroles et
la parole en lumière et dans 76 % des
cas et les prisonniers sont libérés ou
ceux qui sont en quête de justice yoyo
justice est faite
j'ai appris qu'il était emprisonné pour
ses idées bien il se tait film et puis
cet ami sur un blog
la vidéo qu'elle ait été en vie en
revenant de ce travail puis séparés ces
bassins fera maison du lez le chercher
pendant très longtemps qui a été envoyé
en prison comme pour courrier on veut
qu'ils prennent conscience de la chance
qu'ils ont de vivre dans un pays comme
le nôtre est de voir que ailleurs la vie
paraît différente puisque tous les
humains qui ont droit aux mêmes heures
en traitement tourner ses opinions tout
le monde ses idées trop d'exprimer ce
qu'il veut c'est quoi les droits humains
pourquoi la paix liberté l'égalité pb le
justice et la vérité
[Musique]
arrivée très sport votre courage moi
j'ai écrit aux mille pas c'est quoi le
mille pattes et un peuple autochtone qui
est sont en train de se faire voler
leurs terres
bonjour je vous soutiens j'ai su ce que
votre père pense à vous et moi je ne
vois juste mon par trois fois par an
donc je peux vous comprendre et quand
j'ai entendu vos messages que vous avez
envoyé votre part j'ai pleuré et je vous
trouve très courageux et je suis sûr que
votre père reviendra plus vite que vous
ne le pensez je suis avec vous et je le
serai toujours est ce que ça te donne
envie de changer le monde quand tu vas
grand oui vraiment c'est comme novateur
dion on envie de qom
parce qu'on est encore jeune et on peut
encore changer de monde pour l'avenir
bon les unes à ce futur pour que soit ce
sera plus beau quel moment
si toi tu pouvais changer le monde
qu'est ce que tu ferais et pays
je laisserai plus de liberté dans les
pays qui en ont besoin
si on en voit beaucoup de lettres
ça va peut-être comme les idées même si
le leur
danone qui gardait sport
[Musique]